[Musique]
mickaël millero qui a signé ses
interviews de l'agent racines et qui
était avec moi au plateau bonsoir
michael 1,5 à yorick vous retrouve comme
chaque lundi pour lé résultat sport du
week end il y avait de beaux matchs 1
d'ailleurs dans les yvelines
alors on va parler d'un sport dont on ne
parle pas souvent c'est le roller hockey
voilà comme du roller hockey oui c'est
exactement ça c'est du hockey mais avec
des rollers à la place des patins et on
a une très bonne équipe dans les
yvelines les chocs ce d'elancourt et
disputée ce week-end leur dernier match
de la saison 2 et n 4 les encours
tournante assurée à domicile après avoir
mené a été mené mais avoir mené par dont
2 1 à la pause
il s'impose finalement 11 à 4 le
deuxième plus gros score de la saison
pour les locaux on écoute les réactions
deuxième mi temps voilà dès qu'on a
commencé à jouer ça allait mieux quoi le
score reflète quoi
le but c'était de mettre au maximum se
faire plaisir parce qu'il ya deux de nos
joueurs qui s'en vont quand même dans
dans d'autres clubs pour évoluer à plus
haut niveau mais donc le but c'était de
se faire plaisir entre nous et maximum
de buts
il encourt termine cette saison en
milieu de tableau à la 5e place de la
poule sur huit équipes engagées
on va prendre maintenant la direction
michael de clairefontaine est forcément
parler de football
faire jouer là une journée
exceptionnelle pour 1600 enfants les
jeunes footballeurs âgés de 10 à 12 ans
en plus jouer ce samedi 13 avril sur les
terrains d'entraînement de l'équipe de
france à clairefontaine à l'occasion de
la danone nations cup leurs coupes du
monde à eux il y avait notamment des
équipes locales comme trappe encore
guyancourt en écoute les réactions micro
de patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est exceptionnel ce qu'a déjà l'année
dernière on pouvait on n'est pas venu et
ça n'est pas c'est déjà bien d'être là
qu'on perde qu'on gagne au moins sûr
plaisir jouer à clairefontaine
un endroit qui est normalement réservé
uniquement aux à l'élite
les pions toutes les équipes de france
c'est une expérience unique dont elles
vont se rappeler je pense le toute leur
vie après cette journée aucune équipe
lilloise n'est parvenue à se qualifier
pour la grande finale nationale qui se
disputera le 22 juin prochain à paris
merci michael ces résultats et bien
d'autres choses encore dans votre
émission le 7-8 sport c'est à retrouver
dans quelques instants après ce journal
avant